me
高校生になってすぐのことです
私は一つ夢を待ちました
高校に入っていろいろな中学校出身の人と出会って
私はこれまで自分がつながりがなかっただけで自分の地元にはこんなに面白い人達が
いるんだってことを発見して
そしたらもしかしたら
他の高校にももっともっと面白い育つがいてその人たちと一緒に何かをつくったらこれ
はもうめっちゃ楽しいんじゃないかって思って
そして2年越しにその夢が実現しました
私は今年の夏にプロデューサーとして
こんなイベントを開催しました
超学校祭です
これは13校の高校中学校
そして60人以上の中高生した数が集まって作り上げた
一つの学校祭型イベントね学校の垣根を越えて私の地元おびひろ広小路商店街で行い
ました
例えばこんな風に
歌ったり踊ったり
他にも部活動単位で企画に参加してくれたり
中高生が自分の好きなことを表現している姿を見て私の夢が実現してすごく嬉しかった
です
でもこの超学校祭の裏には実はものすごいたくさんの失敗がありました
それはもう数えきれないほどの
私はこれまでプロデューサーとして超学校祭の中で運営に関わっていてミスが起こると
いつもこう思っていました
私がやりたいって言い出したんだから私が全部なんとかしなきゃ
プロデューサーなんだから責任取らなきゃって
そこにとらわれてしまった私は周りが全然見えていなくて
あーこの資料作り忘れてた山に作らないととかお店との連絡するのは3つっやっぱ
ヤバイやらなきゃー
あ小学校祭のパンフレットを客50部頼もうとしてたのに間違えて1500部頼ん
じゃったばカーみたいな
そんな冷静ならを貸さないミスを何回も何回もそのたびに反省するのに私は周りが見え
てないからまた同じことを繰り返してしまって
そうやって一人で抱え込んで抱え込んでい
でも超学校祭1週間前になって
私は限界になっちゃったんです
そして
もう無理だと思って初めて
中高生の運営の皆に大きく声を上げて助けを求めました
ごめんわたしに無理だった一人じゃもうだけができない
受けてって
そしたら
運営の皆がえっそうだったのごめんそんな大変の状況だなんてわかんなかった
今から私俺何できるどうしたらいい
って言ってくれてしかもそうなったら上じゃない友達まで手伝いに来てくれて
で私はそれまで知らなかったんですけど実は運営の中にめちゃくちゃ資料を作るのが
上手い子がいたり
他にも会計の仕事が好きだよ得意だよって人がいたり
そんな感じです小学校祭3日前にはあれよあれよとイベント創立に向けて形作られて
いきました
そして2018年7月29日
私たちは無事小学校祭を開催することができました
ありがとうございます
後日振り返ったときわかったんです
なんでこの超学校祭をゴールに導くことができたのか
これまで私はすごいプロデューサーになりたいって思ってました
一人で全部なんでもできちゃうスーパーんわみたいな
でも違った
私できないんです
やりたいってことはあっても一人じゃ何にも出来なかった
でも自分の弱い部分をさらけ出して
もう無理だって言って初めて小学校祭のメンバーと同じ温度感になって同じ熱量で
一つのプロジェクトを作り上げることができたんです
そして気がつきました
これって
良問を法則なんじゃないかなって
量も言って私の中ではそこにいる人たちがお互いに惹かれ合って尊敬しあって高め合っ
てそして支え合えるようなそんな間柄になることだと思っています
両思いのためには思いが共有されていることが大切なんです
そんなプロジェクトメンバーが生き生き動くための両想いの法則を今日はみなさんにお
伝えしたいなと思います
思いが共有されている状態の両想いを作り出すために
法則は陳腐ルナ3つです
一つ目自分をよく知ること
二つ目自分をさらけ出すこと
3つ目相手をよく知ること
恋愛でもプロジェクトでも量もいなるための限ってコミュニケーションなんです
一つ目の自分をよく知ることでは例えば私は何が好きで苦手で得意で嫌いでーみたいな
そんななんとなく曖昧な部分でわかってそうでわかってないところをきちんと言葉にし
ておくこと
そして2つめの自分をさらけ出すことで
よく強みと彼は最初にチームで共有できたりもするんですけどなかなか自分の弱みとか
恥ずかしいし勇気が出ないしいいにくい部分を言ってしまうこと
そして3つめの相手をよく知ることの前にこの2つ目の自分をさらけ出すことが来るの
は例えば心理学で好意の返報性って言葉があるように先に自分の弱みをさらけ出して
しまうことで私はあなたを信頼していますよっていう証拠になるしそしたら相手も自分
のことをさらけ出して
くれるようになるので二つ目に先に自分をさらけ出してしまうっていうことがポイント
なんです
そんな風にこの両想いの法則を使えばいつかそうですね療法医のための道っていうもの
があってそこへ想いがだんだんつながっていってこの3つの単純な法則を繰り返して
いくことでコミュニケーションが深まっていくんじゃないかなと思います
両前になるために例えば
今はヒトメボ0とか
最初に一瞬見て好きになっちゃったとかあるけどでも結局そこから
思いが繋がっていくのって
どんどんどんどん相手のことを知ってん惹かれ合ってそういうコミュニケーションの
もとに成り立っていることだと思うんです
そんな風にこんな両思いの法則を使ってぜひみなさんにもこれから先にもし何かやり
たいことがあったときには自分の思いを伝えて相手のことをよく知るっていうことを
やってほしいなと思います
さてこれからの私たちの人生
何かをやろうと思った時にはもちろん全ての思いが実ることはないし
両方になるって事もなかなか難しいかなと思います
でもそんなときにもこの両想いの法則を使ってこれがみなさんの心と心を繋ぐキュー
ピットになればいいなと思いますありがとうございました
[拍手]